yeah welcome to this video playing FM
marco from germany and steam of any more
straighter Joan FM playing club not far
away from me actually so we know each
other ok only a six then maybe wants to
take ok let's take and beef I so going
to take them both on exchange Queens
gambit to type of setup ok that's an
active way to play maybe try something
else they're not taking and so on but a
form if he takes on d4 that should be ok
I can also take with a pawn that was my
attention and ok so here maybe 95 Queen
a three this is often interesting for
Queen age 3 C 4 is also now prevented
because I can just take it
so let's go they're threatening 97 it's
a nice little idea yep he prevented that
and that gets me this fyd n the typical
attacking scheme that is quite dangerous
often so we we see how it and how old
will unfold here ok he's playing this
very quickly so hmm ok f 5 m-f 587 is
just telling right why isn't this happen
just hanging with the Queen or how
exactly I can take with the Queen would
somehow I didn't even I didn't even
consider that he could have blundered a
piece down black resins yeah it was
quick yeah it's not not the most
interesting game ever it's just so so on
it's a quick loss and what i wanted to
show is and this little trick there and
like here and now I'm threatening 97 so
if he plays nothing nothing like this
then 97 is very strong the point is that
ok this is just made check but Quinn
takes Bishop H serves as a funny funny
trick that is useful to know ya again
white white is winning face based on the
fact that his Queen hang so this is a
useful little little idea and yeah here
then m form yeah okay antique sticks in
94 is just giving me the piece in other
cases like this here the question is do
I go for a further prep move or do I
continue with a 5
f5 might be might be a bit too much you
can take and check me check cheeky 5 not
shown that doesn't probably doesn't um
does it work sorry yeah but I have have
ways to improve rook a to e1 or
something like that getting the rook
involved or King h1 is also useful
they're taking ideas always f5 and then
prying open the kingside give some wider
the strong attack normally this kind of
setup I'm attacking with all pieces 'um
and this is not very active okay well
thanks for watching